c'est la passion du vélo qui rassemble
cyclistes confirmés et ceux qui
pratiquent occasionnellement ce sport
cette deuxième édition du tout des can
organisée par hervé arcade se pratiquer
en famille et entre amis
en pleine préparation pour la route des
alizés nous sommes donc c'est l'occasion
pour nous deux
d'aller sur les pistes martiniquaise
avait été sauvé de la grosse surprise
parce que j'aime pas l'écouter on m'a
dit qu'ils en avaient donc du coup le
but pour moi c'est déjà de finir le
parcours on verra une guerre ce héros
bien qu'à routine deux anciennes gloires
du cyclisme sont les parrains de cette
édition qui comprend deux circuits un
pour les vélos de route et un autre pour
les vtt en pleine campagne trinitéenne
là je vous permettre à certains
pratiquants de découvrir mes routes
d'entraînement que ben malheureusement
les courses je n'emprunte pas et où le
parent vous est assez bossé voilà donc
s'il permet de découvrir d'autres
circuits d'entraînement tartane vert-pré
grumman man 10 aces et sept maris pour
un retour au point de départ à trinité
le circuit sur route n'était pas de tout
repos
je m'attendais à souffrir d'aucun pas
plus que ça a dû y avait beaucoup de
monde beaucoup de montées oui mais on
est habitué
donc l'essentiel j'ai bouclé c'est
beaucoup mais
subir jalonné cette allure c'est dur la
chaleur l'inventer qui ne finissait pas
j'avoue que j'étais contente de voir
gros-morne parce que elle et elle est
longue
elle est longue et c'est très chaud
invité surprise ti blanc thomas voeckler
il était de retour sur les terres
trinitéenne il a fait ses premières
armes sous le regard paternel de
ferdinand iv racaille et pertinents mais
moi m'ont toujours dit mr g messieurs
arcade mais l'unité betty quand on
partait avec un relais le mardi après
l'école s'entraîner avec les phares de
la voiture qu'on n'a pas des personnes
comme ça qui te suivent
c'est tout ce que j'ai pu faire dans ma
carrière il a à chaque fois une petite
partie du maillot ça lui revient
ça fait plaisir parce que
il fallait aussi qu'elle fasse parce
qu'ils voulaient donner les moyens puis
voilà pour l'anecdote c'est le numéro 44
francky favre du vélo-club samaritaine
qui a remporté l'édition 2010 8 du code
des canons